[Música]
quando eu falo é que fugir à data em que
vocês pensem somente uma parte vocês
pensam os refugiados na síria porque o
que não chega até nós mas freqüentemente
hoje em dia
em 2014 eu estive na república
democrática do congo vai estudar o campo
de refugiados de modo é como vocês podem
ver uma lei fica mais ou menos 35
quilômetros da fronteira com a república
centro africana é aquela linha branca ea
fronteira e também no rio e agora vocês
perguntou o que eu sei lá fazendo já há
alguns anos que eu tenha algumas
questões algumas preocupações que
inquietavam e que eu queria ver
respondidas de uma forma mais
aprofundada dessas questões era por
exemplo como é que elas foram
laboratório que lhes acontece lá como é
viver como refugiado que é um campo
ela está em lata que elas não saem então
tudo isto vamos ter o campeão online
lá vivem mais de 10 mil opções são quase
todas elas oriundas do bug que é capital
da república centro africana e muitas
delas foram contando como é que é o dia
a dia delas ali no campo e eu quando
cheguei a portugal e analisar os dados
que estou com a minha tese de mestrado
eu percebi kan a conversa delas focas
horto ano passado ou no presente momento
a passar delas em bangui elas todas uma
forma ou de outra forma dizem tenha uma
vida boa tem uma vida estável e que ela
precisava tinham filhos em uma escola os
alunos tinham trabalho e até jovens que
freqüentavam o ensino superior mas como
a guerra tudo isso acabou
então pra muitas muitas pessoas a
solução foi atravessar a fronteira e
procon
aqui eu estou com uma refugiada o gasto
com várias mas uma delas é o fim
ela disse que a vida dela em banheira
estável tem trabalho maria mãe do filho
à escola mas com a guerra ela tem que
ter um barco fazendo então fugido basta
ter us ela meus filhos lá dentro de
alguns meses que ela considerava como
ela fugiu para o congo agora ali no
campo de uma lei ela tenta dar uma
aos filhos que os afasta que os abstraia
da realidade em que vivem no campo
por exemplo todos os dias de manhã ela
organiza um horário aos credores um
horário com algumas tarefas para fazerem
isso tarefas pra ajudar em ela é
orientada para e que são compatíveis com
o horário de aulas na escola e ela
decide esta é uma forma que ela usa de
manter ocupados deve sair daquela
realidade e ela disse mancini
eu quero preparar os meus filhos para
serem cidadãos do mundo porque acredito
que vou conseguir ter o saque enquanto
que os filhos estão na escola ela eo
marido o marido dela foi perseguido por
causas políticas elas tenham fugido
durante várias semanas escondido em
vários sítios até conseguir aproximar-se
da fronteira e traçar e procon go e
finalmente no início a família e os dois
enquanto que os filhos estão na escola
eles costumam ir até a floresta o mato
ficar troncos de árvores paulo madeira
conseguirem construir uma tenda mais
fresca do que aquela do plástico em que
elas vivem
além disso e os dois também costumam
cultivar alguns gols na terra mas sofre
disse que isto tem alguns problemas com
deus é água água no campo é muito
escassa ficar saía muitas vezes e ela
escassa quer promover quer pegar as
plantas e também para tomar banho por
exemplo neste campo existem apenas duas
zonas com casas de banho
nós vemos ali o entregariam do uso de um
ato em um dos dois médios do outro dos
homens ea funda zona das casas de banho
quando a água as minhas reúnem em grupos
e vão tomar bem porquê porque enquanto
uma turma banho
as outras ficam é vigiar isto é uma zona
no campo relativamente longe das tendas
elas querem privacidade e além disso
também existe o perigo de haver abuso
sexual e quando a água ajuda juntos mais
uma vez que esta tarefa assumida por
elas
elas saem do campo não algumas
distâncias longas distâncias
porém até hoje mais próximo buscar água
e estou felicíssimo que tem alguns
problemas
a volta de que o campo não existe
rigorosamente
nada no raio de várias dezenas de
quilômetros não exista nada então isso
ao fim não sabe o que vai encontrar e
ela e as colegas dela e não sabem que o
encontrado por encontrar pessoas
estranhas podem encontrar animais
algumas coisas podem acontecer então
ainda e na outra preocupação para ela e
para as outras mulheres também que
quando elas chegam elas não têm um sítio
do quadro nem fresco para descansarem
as tendas são todos iguais são todas do
mesmo tamanho quando pouco mais que uma
cama acaba lá dentro em apenas uma cama
por família quer seja no filme é de uma
pessoa que seja uma família mais
numerosa
então enquanto que eu é sofia marido
dela fazem estas tarefas todas os filhos
estão na escola
neste caso existem duas escolas de
apenas ensinado no ensino primário que
as crianças tenham de 6 12 16 anos vão
sempre a escola eu por exemplo acho que
tem que dividir uma escola na mesma
pisada andarem sempre na monotonia
a professora dos filhos dela dos quatro
filhos e melanie
ela é uma menina de 19 anos ela em
bangui era a universitária estava em
coisas em galera ser professora e a
história dela o passado dela que ela
passou com a guerra e muito muito triste
mas mesmo assim sabe o que ela faz para
conseguir todos os dias
ultrapassar aquilo que ela que ela viveu
e que ela tá ali ia passar e ela com ela
quando ela fugiu ela não vou trouxe
alguns justificam a médica estava então
todos os dias ela uso
além disso ela também é com ela sempre
como ninguém não quero a minha preferida
dela mesmo no campo ela usa a mala
além disso ela também procura maquiar se
ela é uma estratégia que ela usa para se
sentir viva para se lembrar daquilo que
ela foi a vida que ela tinha bastando
que o que ela é e aquilo que ela quer
continuar a ser pra mim foi um gesto de
amor e tal como a minha mania só físico
tem mais pessoas que têm sonhos que tem
problemas que têm medo e ansiedade por
exemplo pierre
você estava com colete é o maior tesouro
deu até administrado
instalei administrado isto foi a única
coisa que eu trouxe como eu para o campo
a única união disse que me ia mostrar a
tese é um novo tempo atrair a tenda fica
lá eu tenho aquela tese mas muito mais
com dida e então tal como o pp também o
desejo é de 90
eu era jogador de basquetebol federado
na república centro-africana ela chegou
até a apresentar essa eleição por várias
ocasiões vez em quando vai copiar para o
campo ruim provisão a um sítio para
jogar e treinar porque têm maior
propensão de leão não poder treinar e
não poder manter em forma
só que este no campo você imaginar e
muito difícil não tem uma equipa é tudo
em terra e não consegue
outra preocupação é comida
o programa de alimentação mundial mas
apenas hoje que fugir átrio
proporcionalmente qual era o número de
pessoas naquela família uma quantidade
por mês da rocha só de óleo de palma
disse e tal como os outros também
disseram que isto é não chega para o
método é por vezes chega apenas por uma
semana
é por isso que muitos refugiados começou
a fifa plantão alguns legumes que é
conseguido introduzir variedade na
alimentação e também por conseguir fazer
face à escassez de comida onde a
preocupação de joel é o estudo eu era
aluno universitário
eu estudava gestão ambiental no campo
está parado e não faz mais nada a não
ser tal e todo dia
no fim da entrevista que eu fiz eu
pergunto onde é que eu era a pensarem
bem e esquecer uma das minhas maiores
intenções ao i era fazer com que aquelas
pessoas sentissem humanizadas e
respeitadas com a minha presença aqui
não olhassem para mim com um corpo
estranho que só ali recolher informação
em portugal
e olha que eu abril sabor é assim mesmo
foi bonito ver e ea visita a portugal
eles que eu conheço e além disso eu
disse eu nunca estive em portugal mas em
portugal fica porque já tenho espanha já
tem a sua e se você já tem um planeta em
outros sítios porque meu pai era
diplomata
aliás foi por uma paz e diplomática foi
morto e toda a minha família eu podia
então ele fugir
você estava em o que é que estes
refugiados que moram aqui não sabem é
que não sabem que ninguém de 3 é que os
torcedores não vão sair da wii
a gente só vai acontecer na realidade
aquilo que se passa e se os campos em
áfrica sobretudo em áfrica são sim
absolutamente isolado todos os dias
acordam e não tem em nenhum objetivo ou
alguns objetivos dar continuidade a ela
pra mim é que o que é mais preocupante é
que aquelas pessoas principalmente
aquelas crianças e os jovens que estão
na terceira via que serve tudo lembra
estas pessoas de que elas estão
refugiadas autonomia a falta de
privacidade são tão pequenas que a vida
deus tem que ser construída fora das
tendas no campo e ao ministro das tendas
no recinto do campo vão construindo a
sua vida e tudo gira à volta da sua
condição de refugiado então elas
partilham os mesmos problemas elas
partilham as mesmas preocupações dos
mesmos métodos e tudo mas lembra
diariamente do que elas são refugiados
mas elas são mais do que isso elas são
pessoas elas são pessoas que antes
conheceram uma terra que era sua
tem um passivo que chamavam casa e no
trabalho elas tenham participação cívica
mas conversa tudo isso perdeu
mas há uma coisa que eu acho super
interessante é que elas não
todos depender da ajuda humanitária
então eu além disso também tem plena
consciência dos seus direitos
por exemplo eu costuma organizar em
comitês as mulheres formaram o comitê da
ge.net elas peões debatem alguns dos
seus direitos reivindicam por e luz e
além disso também organizam algumas
atividades como por exemplo a
comemoração do dia da mulher
isto e que fala deste comitê fala do
tipo existem outros é que os projetos
têm plena consciência de seus direitos
e vocês sabem como é que foi a ajuda que
incluíram a coisa mais básica que sempre
pediram pra quando eu recebi sassa
portugal quando fez pular para dizer às
pessoas o que quer viver como fugir a
tudo o que é viver como fugir atalay
esquecido rotular como fugir a de que
sim que é uma pessoa e é precisamente
isso que eu vim aqui fazer hoje é que eu
peço é que eu não podia me para fazer o
que querem fugir até uma pessoa que
vocês ajudem a divulgar o que é que o
que se passa é que todos juntos possamos
desconstruir estereótipos e mitos
associados a estas pessoas é isto que
elas precisam
nós todos aqui que estamos aqui hoje
realmente nós somos alunos
universitários ou temos emprego o termo
sonho de todos nós temos bastante frágil
né
nós sabemos que de uma forma ou de outra
nós vamos conseguir chegar aos nossos
sonhos vão ficar lá perto porque nós
temos as ferramentas e as oportunidade
para isso
estas pessoas que vocês acham destas
pessoas
quando se pergunta elas sobre o que elas
achavam que é ser o futuro delas como
ela se projetava 11 no futuro que elas
imaginavam que a ser o futuro delas
estas foram algumas das respostas que eu
tive
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]